[SHOUTING QUESTIONS]
>> Dana: THERE WAS A LOT AND
WE ARE GOING TO GET EVERYBODY'S
THOUGHTS ON THE COMMENTARY.
HE SPOKE FOR ABOUT 26 MINUTES.
HE PACKED A LOT IN THERE.
HE HAD A LOT OF I WOULD SAY
DIVISIVE STATEMENTS AND THEN AT
THE END SAID THERE'S NOTHING WE
CAN'T DO IF WE DON'T DO IT
TOGETHER.
SO I GUESS THERE IS UNITY OF THE
END.
SO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT.
JESSE, YOU ARE THE ONE WHO WAS
SILENT.
NOW I AM DYING TO KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING.
>> Jesse: HE'S AN ANGRY MAN,
BITTER MAN.
HE IS HUMILIATED BY THE
AFGHANISTAN SITUATION.
HE IS UPSET WITH THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, WHERE IT SHOULD BE BUT
IT'S NOT TO BE TAKING THE ANGER
OUT ON THE UNVAXXED.
THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN LIED TO FOR
THREE DECADES.
WHY DO YOU TRUST A POLITICIAN OR
THE MEDIA TELLING YOU ANYTHING.
INSTEAD OF UNITING THE COUNTRY
AGAINST THIS PANDEMIC HAD
AGAINST CHINA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE IT CAME FROM, HE'S TRYING
TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY AGAINST
ITSELF FOR POLITICAL
EXPLOITATION.
YOU KNOW WHO PEOPLE TRUST?
THEY TRUST THEIR DOCTOR.
INSTEAD OF DOING ALL THIS THAT
MEANS NOTHING, GIVE THE DOCTORS
THE SHOTS.
HAVE THE DOCTORS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE SHELVE THE SHOTS.
THEY CAN STICK THESE THINGS AND
PEOPLE'S ARMS.
YOU CAN GET RID OF ALL THAT
OTHER MISTRUST WHEN YOU DO THAT.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY POLL TESTED
MANDATES.
HE NEVER SAID MANDATES.
ITS REQUIREMENTS, THAT'S THE NEW
WORD.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MANDATES
VERY INTERESTING SO THERE'S
ABOUT 2 MILLION FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES.
LET'S SAY 70% ARE VAXXED SO
THAT'S HALF A MILLION THAT
AREN'T VAXXED.
HE IS GOING TO FIRE HALF A
MILLION GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES ARE
NOT GETTING THE SHOT?
IF HE DOES THAT, HE IS THE
GREATEST BUREAUCRATIC REDUCER.
HE GETS RID OF HALF A MILLION
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES.
WOW.
THAT WOULD BE A BIG DEAL.
IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN 100
WORKERS AND YOUR COMPANY, YOU'VE
GOT TO JUMP THROUGH ALL THIS RED
TAPE.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIRE PEOPLE TO
GET TO 99.
YOU DON'T DO THAT DURING A LABOR
SHORTAGE AND IT'S GOING TO
CREATE TURMOIL IN THE ECONOMY.
HE WAS ALSO SPEAKING TO THESE
VACCINE EXTREMISTS.
THESE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE TWO
SHOTS AND I CAN'T WAIT FOR THEIR
BOOSTER.
THEY WEAR A BODY CONDOM WHEN
THEY LEAVE THE HOUSE AND THEY
ARE LIVING LIKE IT'S SPRING
2020, DEEP QUARANTINE.
AFRAID TO GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE.
HE IS TELLING THEM I'M ON YOUR
SIDE.
IT'S THESE NASTY UNVAXXED
MASSES, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HURTING US.
THEN HE SAYS IF THE ECONOMY
DOESN'T RECOVER, IT'S THEIR
FAULT.
HE HAS ALREADY SET UP THE EXCUSE
THAT IF THIS DOESN'T WARN HER
OUT, IT'S THEIR FAULT.
HE SAID WE HAVE DONE OUR PART,
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
QUOTE-UNQUOTE AND THEN LICENSE
HAS GOVERNORS OR DISCOURAGING
VACCINATIONS.
THAT'S A BALD-FACED LIE.
NOT A SINGLE GOVERNOR HAS SAID
THAT.
DECLARING WAR ON ABBOTT AND
DeSANTIS.
HE'S COMING FOR YOU.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED MOMENT
CLEANUP.
WHEN HE SAID WE ARE FREE FROM
THIS IN JULY, HE'S BACKPEDALING.
IF HE GETS AWAY WITH THIS
PARAGRAPH, HE WILL BE
BLOODTHIRSTY.
IMAGINE WHAT HE GETS AWAY WITH
NEXT.
>> Dana: GREAT THOUGHTS.
I'M GLAD WE CAME TO YOU.
GREG, HE SAID MANY OF US ARE
FRUSTRATED WITH THE 80 MILLION
WHO AREN'T TRUE.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
I LIVE WITH ONE.
YOU HEAR THAT FROM THE MEDIA.
>> Dana: PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERVIEWING.
IS THAT SPEECH GOING TO PERSUADE
ANY OF THOSE PEOPLE?
>> Greg: THE GREAT UNIFIER IS
SAYING THOSE WHO ARE VAXXED ARE
THAT OF THOSE WHO AREN'T.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S FAIR TO GIN UP MORE
ANIMOSITY DIVISION.
HE SAID THAT THE UNVAXXED OF THE
NEW TERRORISTS, THAT'S WHAT HE
DID.
HE SHOWED MORE ANGER TOWARD THAT
80 MILLION.
THAT HE ACTUALLY WON'T SPECIFY
WHAT CONSTITUTES 80 MILLION.
HE SHOWED MORE ANGER TOWARD THEM
THAN THE ORDERLY AND KIND
TALIBAN.
THE VERY BUSINESSLIKE -- HE LIED
SO MUCH.
THE WHOLE THING WAS HE WAS
BLOWING HIS OWN HORN BECAUSE HE
BLEW IT IN AFGHANISTAN.
THIS WAS HIS WAY TO SHOW THAT
MAYBE HE IS COMPETENT SO WE HAD
TO GIN UP THE FEAR.
INTERESTING GAME OF SAYING
EVERYTHING IS GREAT BUT IT COULD
JUST TOTALLY GOTO HELL IN A
MINUTE AND IT WOULDN'T BE MY
FAULT.
THEN HE'S COMPARING BEFORE HE
GOT THERE UNTIL NOW.
PEOPLE HAVE TO REMEMBER THIS IS
A GUY THAT SAID DON'T TRUST THE
VACCINES.
THAT'S THE GUY, THE SAME GUY WHO
SAID THAT IS NOW SAYING PEOPLE
WHO SAY THAT ARE PUBLICLY
DANGEROUS OR ENDANGERING PUBLIC
HEALTH.
BLOCKING PUBLIC HEALTH WAS THE
WORD HE USED.
HE TALKED A LOT.
THE THING THAT BUGS ME MOST
ABOUT IT IS THAT HE FOUND AN
EASY TARGET.
IT'S A TARGET THAT THE MEDIA
LIKES TO PUNCH.
IT'S A PUNCHING DOWN THING BUT
HE WON'T SAY WHO THEY ARE.
I DON'T TRUST ANYONE, ESPECIALLY
HIM, WHO SAYS THE ONLY WAY TO
GET BACK TO NORMAL IS TO DO X.
BUT THEY KEEP CHANGING X BECAUSE
OF HOW IT AFFECTS THEM
POLITICALLY.
HIS GOVERNMENT SAID WE ARE NOT
DOING MASK MANDATES.
THREE WEEKS AGO.
I'M SORRY, VACCINE MANDATES.
THAT CHANGED.
HE HAS BASICALLY CREATED
UNLIMITED POWER.